who was the individual that uh gave you
permission to access the emails well the
attribution from my story is sources of
Twitter and that's what I'm going to
refer to okay
okay must contact you Mr tahibi again
the attribution for my story is sources
at Twitter Mr taibi have you had
conversations with Elon Musk
I have okay uh Mr Tybee did Mr musk
place any conditions
yield for a second uh as long as my time
is not used are you trying to get
journalists no I'm not trying no I'm not
I am asking no well if you would let me
finish uh you and you had conversations
with him not you said you weren't going
to agree to who your sources were I'm
not asking you your Source I'm asking
you if you had conversations with the
owner of Twitter oh okay uh Mr stripey
who was your source for these documents
are you asking them to reveal sources no
I'm not saying that that's exactly what
she was doing and it is outrageous and
actually quite chilling to watch that
exchange when you understand what she's
trying to do